il ne fallait pas avoir le tournis
samedi 15 janvier au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les coureurs cyclistes par équipes de
trois ou quatre ont parcouru la piste
durant pas moins de six heures ils
avaient tous un objectif en tête faire
le plus grand nombre de tours possible
en se relayant sur la piste faire un
relais d'une heure et demie c'est quand
même l'on essaie de faire d'eux de
relais quoi de trois quarts d'heure à
peu près pour essayer d'optimiser un peu
car le passage de relais c'est le moment
clé de la course il faut être très très
rapide dans le passage de relais passage
du transpondeur donc à son équipier et
généralement on perd deux tours voire
trois tours mais là on perd on peut
perdre en facilement un ou deux tours et
on peut faire perdre la course sur le
passage de relais dans les 23 équipes de
cette seconde édition il y avait tous
types des sportifs venus de toute la
france la particularité c'est d'avoir
des des champions des grands champions
aujourd'hui nous avons les médailles
olympiques et avec des abonnés et des
gens de toutes les catégories parmi ces
grands champions il y avait notamment
ceux de l'équipe de france nous en tant
que sprinteur ça nous permet de faire
des volumes notamment plus important et
puis de de partager un moment convivial
avec un autre athlète qui remettra un
dossard et cbs mais anna informations
remontent au championnat du monde qui
avait eu lieu en octobre dernier sur la
teneur de sa serre plaisir et rigoler
avec les amis puisque jean bonne
ambiance donc moi j'aime bien faire ce
genre de choses après plus de 1070 tour
soit environ 260 km c'est l'équipe
assurances vélo qui a remporté la coupe
elle était composée de tom derache
melvin landerneau et baptiste et didier